c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir les défis afrique-inde
emmanuel macron le président français a
été réélu à 58,5 % des suffrages va-t-il
continuer la politique qu'il a menée sur
le continent lors de son premier mandat
nous poserons la question à notre invité
antoine glaser coauteur du livre le
piège africains de macron aux éditions
fayard
la journée mondiale de la lutte contre
le paludisme cette maladie transmise par
le moustique a causé la mort de plus de
six cent mille personnes en 2020 96 %
des décès sont en afrique pourquoi le
continent est il si touchée on fera le
point avec notre invité le professeur
daouda n'diaye pas ludologue experts
indépendants de l'om s
emmanuel macron a donc été réélu pour
cinq ans un nouveau mandat où il se
refuse de parler de continuité quelle
sera donc la politique menée par le chef
de l'état réélu sur le continent
africain pour en parler nous recevons
antoine glaser spécialiste des questions
africaines et coauteur avec pascal héros
du livre le piège africains de macron
aux éditions fayard merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en train de blazer
alors je le disais emmanuel macron ne
veut pas de continuité pour le continent
il avait lors de son premier mandat
parler de rupture notamment avec la
françafrique alors est-ce qu'il y aura
au moins sur le continent une continuité
dans la rupture ou issue à une rupture
de la continuité bastien c'est vrai
qu'on sait pas encore ce que bien sûr ce
que macron 2 faire par rapport à
maquereau 1 on imagine mal qui changent
que trompe complètement sa stratégie
africaine qui était surtout une
stratégie multilatérale
européaniser tout ce qui était de
l'appareil sécuritaire en afrique +
finalement le peu dire quand même
l'échec de la france de barkan au mali
donc tout ça fait qu'on a un président
qui est quand même un certain retrait
français ce qui est certain c'est je
pense que c'est la méthode qui va
changer ça veut dire emmanuel macron
était toujours en train de dire la
france n'a pas vocation est en première
ligne la france n'a plus vocation à être
gendarme de l'afrique mais on voyait
bien quand même que la realpolitik le
rattraper constamment et qu'on était un
peu comme ça dans une dent on savait pas
trop si la france était toujours à la
manoeuvre et je pense que emmanuel
macron d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on
n'a pas tellement tendue sur l'afrique
bon il est vrai que la campagne a été
courte mais on l'entend plus tellement
finalement sur l'afrique bien sûr il ya
eu l'ukraine mais en dehors de ça ce qui
se dit un peu dans les coulisses du
pouvoir c'est que il sera beaucoup moins
en première ligne il veut que la france
finalement fasse un peu parlé beaucoup
plus non seulement les partenaires
africains mais aussi les partenaires
européens pour peu que la france soit
dans cette fameuse françafrique qui
décriaient mais qu'il a plus ou moins
poursuivi par realpolitik les 3e mandat
des chefs d'état l'adoubement du fils
déby au tchad tout ça aux nues brouilla
moment et jeunes africains comprenais
pas mais qu'est ce que veut la france
est lui ont dit qu'il ya rupture on
continue comme auparavant alors
justement on a vu notamment emmanuel
macron lors du sommet afrique france on
a vu qu'il y avait une volonté de parler
à cette jeunesse africaine à la société
civile les chefs d'état n'étaient pas
conviés est ce qu'il ne sait pas là dans
ce qu'elle a éloigné de la realpolitik
ben c'est complètement je viens c'est
très bien géré la difficulté c'est qu'il
est quand même il n'est pas président un
film tant qu'il est présent la
république française donc à chaque fois
ah bon si quand il anime la société
civile c'est très bien c'est la
stratégie qui consiste finalement à
valoriser l'afrique des africains à
travers la culture il veut créer avec
achille mbembe une maison voilà deux des
africains à paris et c'est donc c'est ça
c'est très important
finalement au niveau de la valorisation
de s'intéresser à prendre de l'afrique
etc mais la realpolitik quand il ya
quand même un certain nombre de coups
d'état quand il ya des problèmes en
afrique à ce moment là c'est le
président emmanuel macron qui parle en
tant que chef des armées et à ce moment
là il a du mal il est dit toujours
lui-même qu'il ait toujours des deux
côtés en même temps mais parfois c'est
très compliqué alors justement comment
composer avec ces chefs d'état africains
il ya des chefs d'état qui sont soit
vieillissant au pouvoir depuis des
décennies je pense à paul biya à dany st
denis sassou n'guesso il ya ces jeunes
parfois même plus jeune que lui un mât à
mettre des billes est plus jeune que
emmanuel macron mais qui sont arrivés au
pouvoir par un coup d'état un coup de
force comment composer avec ces nouveaux
chefs d'état africains où les anciens
qui est symbolise un peu la françafrique
que lui veut rejeter et va simplement
respecter l'afrique des africains je
veux dire c'est aux africains de gérer
aussi leurs relations et de pas toujours
donné l'impression qu'il va dire allah
c'est bien là c'est mal là quand c'est
les intérêts de la france au tchad et de
l'armée française à ce moment là la
france à double une dynastie une section
dynastique un autre endroit quand c'est
en guinée ou au mali dira non là il est
légitime et cetera au bout d'un moment
ce quand même il faut inverser la donne
vient c'est la fille des africains il
faut arrêter dans la françafrique
d'autant que emmanuel macron il est
arrivé en disant maintenant je vais
heureux européaniser finalement avec mes
partenaires européens la sécurité en
afrique je veux que ça soit lui le
multilatéralisme d'ailleurs entre nous
il fait une grande réunion sur la
société civile à montpellier avec les
jeunes africains mais les diasporas mais
en même temps il revoyait quand même
tous les chefs d'état dans les sommets
économiques ou les sommets à bruxelles
union européenne afrique donc il joue
quand même a toujours un peu sur les
deux tableaux alors il ya quand même
quelques succès même s'il ya eu des
échecs je pense aux la question
mémorielle avec l'algérie où ça a
commencé à prendre mais finalement il ya
eu des tensions il ya notamment un
succès probablement avec le rwanda
scellé par me fait partie le rwanda fait
partie des pays qui se disent satisfaits
de la réélection des manuels macron je
vous propose d'écouter le porte parole
adjoint du gouvernement du rwanda qui
salue cette réélection au micro de notre
correspondant simon rolfes
l'élection de monsieur marc pons est une
bonne chose est une chose positive parce
que c'est l'un des présidents après les
évènements qui ont eu tendance à 94 qui
a fait le plus pour améliorer les
relations entre le rwanda et la
république française des relations qui
n'était pas
qu'ils n'étaient pas bonnes c'est l'un
des présidents si c'est pas le seul qui
a fait plus pour
la reprise des relations diplomatiques
avec le rwanda et on a vu directement
après les conséquences il ya eu
l'ambassadeur qui a été nommé ça ainsi
peut-on donc imaginer ce que pouvoir
pouvoir se passer en cinq ans alors
antoine glaser ce bilan pour le rwanda
bilan est positif pour le rwanda c'est
vrai que président mails macron était
vraiment jusqu'au bout avec le rapport
du clair même si certains considèrent ça
n'a pas été assez loin et c'est empêche
qu avec le rwanda sauf que le rwanda
c'est quand même pas justement c'est pas
un ancien pré carré de la france en
afrique c'est pas les anciennes colonies
françaises c'était une sorte d'arrogance
dedans du président mitterrand c'était
des anciennes colonies belges et du coup
pour préserver cet espace francophone y
avait cette intervention de la france au
rwanda mais très franchement c'est très
finalement en plus emmanuel macron il
est très fan de paul kagamé et considère
que peut faire beaucoup de choses avec
une en digital il peut il peut
finalement il dit toujours oui va comme
ça c'est un modèle pour les autres chefs
d'état africains mais le rwanda c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
particulier
le problème c'est des autres c'est un
certain nombre et 22,2 crade qui sont au
pouvoir et avec emmanuel macron quand
par exemple ali bongo le gabon est
actuellement il est actuellement au
secrétariat permanent au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies donc la
france a besoin de la voix du gabon qu
avec le ghana de 2022 2024 lorsque par
exemple denis sassou nguesso il a bien
été reçu à l'elysée parce que au niveau
de l'environnement la france a besoin de
ces chefs d'état parce que la france se
dit ben oui mais nous c'est le deuxième
poumon de l'humanité donc très important
de soutenir ccpc président l'a alors une
dernière question a rapidement par
rapport à l' influence russe noté au
mali en centrafrique est ce que la
france que rattraper son retard et
comment justement faire face à cette
influence
notamment voix au mali avec les
mercenaires du du groupe privé wagner
mais la france n'a pas rattrapé son
retard la france a été en position
dominante pendant 30 ans de 70 jusqu'à
la chute du mur de berlin maintenant
c'est l'afrique mondialisé et finalement
le les russes c'est de l'opportunisme
quand la france un peu retirée de
centrafrique c'est eux qui sont allés
faire la négociation en centrafrique
quand la france se retire du mahdi c'est
eux qui vont malice et l'opportunisme et
le cameroun mais en plus il y en avait
un accord militaire cameroun russie mais
sauf que les wagner ils y vont à bab à
bas bruit et à bas prix et c'est pour ça
que la france considère que les uns les
armadas comme comme le barca que c'est
fini c'est une autre période maintenant
il regrette de ne pas avoir fait des
opérations spéciales d'avoir maintenu un
peu comme ça un peu hors sol une armée
conventionnelle donc le monde change
l'afrique change encore plus vite que le
reste du monde parle que de l'ukraine
mais l'afrique se mondialise et c'est
vrai que la place de la france
maintenant enfin je veux dire le
problème de macron à mâcon 2 ces low
profile jedir c'est vrai créateur il va
y avoir beaucoup mal intervention à mon
avis de emmanuel macron dans cette
deuxième période que son premier
quinquennat merci infiniment antoine
glaser pour votre décryptage rappelle
que vous êtes l'auteur de le piège
africains de macron aux éditions fayard
merci beaucoup c'est ce lundi la journée
mondiale de la lutte contre le paludisme
cette maladie potentiellement mortelle
causée par des parasites transmis par
des piqûres de moustiques en 2020 l'eau
à metz a recensé
241 millions de cas de paludisme dans le
monde le nombre de décès est lui estimé
à plus de 600 milles en 2020 on en parle
tout de suite avec notre invité le
professeur down diane pas ludologue
experts indépendants de l'om est-ce
directeur du centre international de
génomique appliquée et de surveillance
sanitaire ucad sigas sénégal j'espère je
me suis pas trompé
merci d'être avec nous professeurs
alors je le disais 95% des cas de
paludisme et 96 des % des décès liés au
paludisme sont en afrique ce chiffre
paraît disproportionnée pourquoi le
continent africain est il aussi touchés
par le paludisme merci beaucoup varié en
fait c'est parce que vous venez de
camper le sujet parce que vous l'avez
parfaitement dix ans les deux tiers des
cas de mortalité et de morbidité les ide
en afrique où plusieurs raisons d'abord
sur le plan environnemental
la palu est une maladie à transmission
vectorielle donc transmis ce qu'on
voulait au départ un vecteur à travers
l'environnement tout le monde sait qu en
afrique il les conditions qui s'y sont
favorables à cet âge mischer not my à la
chaleur et l'humidité les deux
conditions favorisent la publication des
vecteurs cette population des vecteurs
est à l'origine de beaucoup de problèmes
parce que s'ils avaient été là qui
transmet la maladie ne pas raser d'une
personne à une autre et qui c'est qui
ceux qui on va voir le doublement de la
maladie donc ne plus agir c'est
l'environnement
la chaire limité parfois malheureusement
la promiscuité qui est là et parfois il
ya des conditions de vie qui pose
problème par rapport à beaucoup de
choses qui font que aujourd'hui le
problème demeure entier malheureusement
ou heureusement
l'effort consenti aujourd'hui pour
endiguer toute maladie on l'a vu avec le
gouverneur n'a pas été présent par
rapport au palu en afrique où on va être
d'accord donc donc ccsa également
l'accès aux soins parce que très souvent
pour jerry maladie quelques le pas lui
qui peut gérer sur le plan de la
létalité de la mobilité c'est facile pas
c'est une maladie qui se trace qui peut
être traitée et qui peut être prévenue
facilement si les conditions sont
réunies notamment campus technologique
et facilement les malades qu'on puisse
le traiter elle a beaucoup de cas de
mortalité de but alors ça c'est le
tableau sombre on va quand même parler
de choses positives notamment
on va on va se rendre au burkina faso où
chaque année plus de 50 % de la
population est touchée par la maladie un
chiffre effrayant même si dans le pays
les sports demeure grâce à des essais
cliniques qui ont montré leur efficacité
ils sont effectués par une équipe de
scientifiques reportage de notre
correspondant kalidou sy
à première vue on pourrait croire que
nous sommes dans un simple centre de
santé et pourtant derrière ces murs des
centaines de chercheurs travaillent sans
relâche dans l'espoir de trouver le
vaccin pour lutter contre l'une des
maladies les plus meurtrières d'afrique
le paludisme situé à une centaine de
kilomètres de ouagadougou
l'institut de recherche en sciences de
la santé de nanoro a été créée en 2008
par cet homme le professeur allais doute
into aujourd'hui il est fier de nous
montrer le potentiel vaccin tant espéré
celle là où nous conservons nos vaccins
dans c'est le flux thater parce que
l'état latent
pratiquant cette vente pas plus pas
moins et vous constaté également que on
utilise l'énergie solaire pour
connecter nos réfrigérateurs et nos
corps et nos congélateurs qui conservent
la parcelle parce que l'énergie doit
être
les essais cliniques de l'équipe
scientifique du professeur tinto qui
travaille avec des chercheurs de
l'université d'oxford au royaume-uni
sexe ont démontré que leur vaccin
pouvait atteindre un taux d'efficacité
de 77% des résultats obtenus grâce à des
appareils médicaux ultra moderne cette
machine vous permet en même temps qui
vous fait votre numération formule
sanguine et vous dit si vous avez le
paludisme ovale et c'est ici à nanoro
que la validation de cet appareil ça
fait pour pouvoir être le dit si bien
dans le monde entier la recherche
pourrait encore prendre plusieurs années
et en attendant la commercialisation
d'un vaccin le dr tinto rappelle que le
meilleur traitement reste la prévention
mais sur moustiquaires imprégnées
d'insecticide parce que les mosquées à
l'enfer les plus serrées moyens de
prévention très efficace et nous disons
aux populations jusqu'à présent nous
n'avons pas encore de vaccin contre le
paludisme nous sommes dans la phase
d'essais cliniques et il faut pas se
faire d'illusions il faut vraiment
appliquer ses méthodes écrivains sont là
avec 11 millions de malades du paludisme
par an et près de 10 mille décès
le burkina faso fait partie des dix pays
les plus touchés au monde mais grâce à
la recherche le nombre de décès a chuté
de 17 3% entre 2016 et 2019
alors on l'a vu dans le reportage
professeurs la prévention est très
importante mais il ya aussi ce vaccin
qui est une lueur d'espoir est ce que le
progrès avance et ce qui est peu par
rapport à ce vaccin est ce qu'il est
accessible aux populations oui il faut
dire que le vaccin effectuera
aujourd'hui homologué par le zonta de la
santé depuis octobre 2021 et qui est là
aujourd'hui qui est et pc d'entre api
notamment au ghana au mali au burkina au
kenya et qui prouve aujourd'hui une
unité parfaite mais également une
efficacité parce que la vie d'après les
résultats obtenus que 30% des enfants
que ce vaccin le jeu réagir je dois
rappeler qu'il ya aujourd'hui au moins
un million de da enfants aux yeux des
critiques en tout cas ouvert par rapport
à ce vaccin là tendu poussant à la
prévente ou protéger contenant du graff
donc c'est pas le grand soir de la
mortalité donc oui à délicieux lieu
d'espoir on pense que s'ils savent
accent est mis à la disposition de la
communauté internationale en afrique au
sud du sahara dans les pays les plus
endémiques dont quatre en chômage élevé
ont pourri vous recevez au moins
quarante
années et pour ça il faut des moyens et
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et on n'a
pas mis autant de moyens dans cette
lutte contre le palu que dans la lutte
contre les causes il se fout car je fais
un appel moi parce qu'en réalité
aujourd'hui si vous voici on voit
l'effort consenti on a besoin
pratiquement annuellement de 6,8
milliards de dollars américains ou
pouvoir lutter efficacement contre le
palu en matière de coûts d'élimination
en 2020 avec 3 800 millions de dollars
donc moins de la moitié et si on prend
le cas de la richesse pour kadhafi le 6
août où on a besoin de 650 millions de
dollars ou de la richesse et accueille
plus d'un peu plus de 600 millions donc
si c'est moins la faible je ne pense
partir des mots qu'on puisse arriver à
melle malgré la présence du vaccin
malgré les interventions qui ont pour
nom sur cette préparation duquel on
s'est donné accès à sa cité et et dr je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse arriver
rapidement maîtrisé s'est pendu même si
on doit le dire il ya eu beaucoup de
progrès il ya beaucoup de pays qui ont
illuminé le palu en
2020 après 23 pays
à peine 12 malheureusement en afrique où
le palais pose problème est que plus
beau deux pays le dernier en date c'est
l'algérie en 2019 si on voit aujourd'hui
les pays qui le palais en de l'intérieur
de la chine
donc oui
beaucoup merci le message est passé
merci beaucoup c'est la fin du journal
de l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]